people of the internet retro tour here
and today we are going to rank all 39
suits for our boy Peter Parker all right
so let's start out with the digital
Deluxe skins which I actually don't have
big thanks to PlayStation for actually
providing me with a free copy of the
game unfortunately it did not include
the digital Deluxe suits so we're going
to start off with those we got the
apocalyptic Stone monkey 25th Century
arantia and the Tactical suit
apocalyptic dude I'm sorry F tier F tier
any suit that has the hair sticking out
is just automatic F tier for me don't
like it for miles on the one that he
gets at the end of the game don't like
it for Peter the rest of the suits okay
honestly if it didn't have the hair
sticking out I'd probably rank it a d
but I don't know man just not a fan at
all of the hair sticking out thing they
got going on Stone monkey here dude this
one's like a cross between a Power
Ranger with a Power Ranger
villain it's not quite F tier but I'm
going to put it in D here oh man yikes
this one wo I think it's going to be F
tier here by the way guys this is all
totally my own opinion obviously as for
my criteria I'm basing this on a variety
of things some of these suits I know a
lot about others I don't know much about
so it's totally my own personal
preference again you're entitled to your
own opinion all right the orania suit or
whatever it is here of the digital
Deluxe that is probably the best one of
those extra skins in my opinion even
then though I don't think it's great ah
probably not even a b tier I'm going to
stick with C tier for that one and then
the tacal suit here we'll go D tier but
I do think it's better than the stone
monkey suit there all right so now we're
getting into skins that I actually have
the saving livit this is the one that
you get through the Yuri quest line
there's a look at the different
variations there again I'm getting some
big Power Ranger Vibes here white ranger
anybody
anybody you I don't even know if this is
the right word but it's like there's a
total lack of depth with this suit it
looks like everything is just one
complete piece you know it's like where
does it even go go on how do you even
put this on it's like they want the
pants and the top to be a separate piece
but yet from the texture and everything
they do not look like a separate piece
overall way too much going on here in
this one I'm going to put it at D tier
and I will put it above the stone monkey
but below the other one here O Okay the
Craven suit next this one man I really
want to like this one more than I do
it's not bad and I mean it's definitely
like a unique look the fact that you are
looking very similar to Craven so I feel
like I got to go at least a C tier on it
here's a look at the other styles that
you get with this one and I don't know I
probably like the default one best
actually yeah getting a good look at it
now here in game I think I'm good with
it at a c tier I do like that it's
Unique and that it is very distinct from
the other suits in the game and
obviously borrows heavily from Craven
and his style life story suit man I just
gosh I don't know I'm trying to think of
a reason not to give this one an F tier
I mean obviously inspired by Ant-Man but
guys come on spider Man suits as a whole
much better than Ant-Man suits no
offense Ant-Man it's like Spider-Man if
he went to outer space maybe I could be
persuaded to go up to a d tier yeah it's
not quite F tier level I'll I'll give it
at least a d tier yeah definitely D tier
for this one and probably at the bottom
of the D tier list as well all right
next we have the black and gold suit no
alternate styles for this one so what
you see is what you get here and I
really like the idea behind this one
sort of that circuitry pattern almost
like it's the internals of the suit but
even though I like the idea behind it
I'm still not loving it taking a look at
it in game now I mean black and gold
does look really good together I still
doubt I would ever use this skin at any
point and really when you're actually
playing in game you lose out on a lot of
those little intricate details of like
the circuitry and everything so let's
see D or C I think I'll go C tier with
that one all right here we have the new
red and blue suit again no alternate
styles for this one so the blue here has
sort of a shine to it I mean really the
whole suit but it especially stands out
on the blue on the front you've got the
black spider in the center and on the
back you have the red spider here here's
a look at it in game and I'm liking this
one it it's definitely my favorite so
far I don't think this one's going to
compare to some of the other suits that
we're going to get to here shortly but
so far I think it's easily the best one
that we've seen that classic look I mean
it's iconic for a reason right and of
course this one has some different
variations on the classic look that we
know and love but that's the thing about
Spider-Man right he's changed ched a
little bit in all the variations over
the years all right but where to put you
I think we might have our first B tier
here with that one up next we have the
iron spider suit so this one has that
very metallic look and another thing I
love about this one is the fact that it
changes the spider arms you got to
remember to check that because it does
change on some of these different
variations this is another one though
that doesn't have any other style so
it's just the style that you see right
here and I like this one quite a bit I
mean I don't love the metal look for
Spider-Man but if you're going to do it
I think this iron spider suit does a
pretty good job at that all right but
where to put it I'm kind of going back
and forth between B and C I definitely
don't think it's as good as the one that
we have right now the classic one there
but I think it's a lot better than these
so maybe we just put it here at the
front of the C tiers for now all right
you guys know what's next it is time if
you're enjoying the video so far and you
want to see me do a ranking for the
Miles Morales suits then make sure to
give this video a thumbs up really helps
it spread to more people black suit our
first s tier immediately s tier like no
debate whatsoever I don't even need to
look at it in game I'll show it to you
in game here because it's so freaking
awesome not only do they give us the
black suit though you have multiple
styles with the black suit so you've got
the regular one here and then you've got
this one which I guess is just sort of a
different shade of black also the eyes
are a bit smaller on this one the white
easily the worst of this group right
here I don't think I would ever use that
skin this one though let's rock this one
for a second here on this one what I
love about it is at first you don't even
notice this until you really start to
look but look at those subtle red and
blue accents you get the red on the
right shoulder of Spider-Man there the
whole right side you see and then the
blue on the left just constantly
shifting As you move it around this suit
I mean yes I grew up seeing the suit a
lot in the Spider-Man shows and the
comics back then but it is really hard
to go against this one I I think it's an
immediate s tier quite possibly the best
suit in the game we'll just have to see
as we go through all right the stealth
suit here you know this one is really
growing on me at first I didn't like
this one at all again no alternate
Styles here so what you see is what you
get but if I imagine Spider-Man going on
a true stealth Mission you know he
doesn't want to be detected at all
obviously you don't want to be going in
with the bright red and blue or
something metallic I really like the
looks of this one so it's not quite a
tier definitely not s tier but for its
specific purpose I'm comfortable putting
it in a solid B tier right there all
right next we have the upgraded suit and
I actually like this one a lot I know I
said with the Yuri suit that I didn't
like how it looked all like one piece
but then kind of like separate pants and
top at the same time this one sort of
has a bit of those vibes going on as
well but it's not nearly as busy
everywhere else and it just works for me
I like kind of the darker wait that's
black right is that dark blue or black
I'm pretty sure it's black I love the
black and red obviously black and red
always goes very well together the super
tiny spider on the front I don't love
that but I don't really strongly dislike
it either here's a look at it in game so
you can see on the back they go with the
white spider so that gives us what three
total color there we got red we got the
black and then we got the white I don't
think it looks as good as the classic
red and blue but everything else about
the suit is so good that I think I'm
going to put it in a tier oh and I'm so
tempted to actually bump this one up
right now you know what let's do that
let's go and bump this one up I'm going
to put you right there in the a tier
category it's our list people we reserve
the right to change it as we go along
fantastic for suit I am not a fan of the
default one I just the blue and black I
like it on some of the mile suits but
here it's just not working for me the
classic one looks a little bit bit
better but it's just so the the the
spider it it doesn't look like a spider
at all and I know it's trying to sort of
hint at the Fantastic 4 but if you're
going to go that route then I'd prefer
something much more like this third
style right here even then this is not
one of my favorite suits I doubt I would
ever use it let's go ahead and throw it
on here and see what it looks like when
you're actually web swinging in game you
know what I will say in game I think
this one looks much better than just
sitting and looking at it in the menu
when you're in motion something about
that blue though I'm just not loving the
blue it's like almost purple I think
you're fit nicely here in the C tier
definitely below these others and
probably a little bit better than these
though upgraded classic okay this one I
like better than the black one that we
looked at before let's see it was this
one right here the upgraded suit but
this one here bringing in the blue I
think it looks so much better I don't
even know if you need it's like a little
bit too much black and just where
they're using the black I don't know I
don't I don't love it but it's still one
of the better suits in the game for now
I'm going to go up to a tier with this
one but I'm going to put it in front of
the red and black one here the web suit
this one here is one of the classic ones
that I'm just not generally a fan of
that red is too dark for me I'm going to
put it in B tier cuz it is still a
classic suit and that combo always looks
great together and I'm even okay with
the webs having that different style but
something about the darkness of the red
and I mean even the blue is really dark
I just not not loving it the webbed
black suit however ladies and gentlemen
you already know another one straight to
S tier I mean look at how good this
looks even in game it looked great in
the movies it looks great in the game
just as soon as I got this one it took
me back to seeing Spider-Man 3 for the
first time and it looks great even today
I think this suit holds up really well
so yes people of the internet all the
way up to the top notice a theme here
with our s tier so far we'll see if that
changes but right now only two slots in
the S tier category next we have the
iron spider armor here which has a
couple of different styles and you know
what I'm really curious if I put on the
blue one let's see do the abilities if I
go over oh so it does change that is
crazy you get the gold arms with that
one this is kind of cool I this the more
I look at this suit it's kind of growing
on me let me go ahead and switch back to
the default style all right all right
yeah yeah yeah now that I'm looking at
this ingame I'm liking it a lot more big
time Iron Man Vibes of course of course
here you go here's a look at the spider
arms right there you get to see that
gold and that looks pretty nice man I
got to say okay for sure this one is at
least a b tier for me at least a b tier
maybe even a when I first started I
probably would have put it C but I'm
going to go B here and honestly I think
I may like it the best of the B so far
then we have the secret wars Civil War
suit complete with four total different
styles and this one's okay I guess like
if you imagine Spider-Man going on a
military Mission maybe he would wear
something like this I think of all the
Styles I like the third one best this is
one category where if you go with a
style like this I feel like you might as
well go all in this one here it's like
they're trying to have their foot in
both worlds like yeah you can tell he's
Spider-Man but also kind of this
military Ops Spider-Man as well and
again here I'm curious if I pick this
one do we actually get camo arms does it
change the arms to camo no okay they're
just silver I was going to say if we get
camo arms that might bump it up a bit I
think this one slots comfortably here in
the C tiers for now spider Punk oh my
man obviously a great character in the
movies but I'm just not feeling this
suit you guys just not feeling the suit
I might even have to go D tier for this
one I think he's better than the monkey
and better than the whatever they called
this one but this is not a suit that I
would ever wear if you are into this
suit though he does have some different
styles I think my favorite part of the
suit though are the shoes you got to
love the shoes this one you got the red
you got the black here you got the white
here I think I like the black best
though of all the Styles I think this
one on the far right here the black and
red that might be my favorite still
though even these Styles I don't think
they can save it from D tier for me the
homemade suit here I mean they did a
good job bringing it to the game I'll
say and sort of representing it here in
the game but it's just not a great suit
I mean it's it's homemade for a reason
right he did the best he could I just I
don't love this one at all don't like
the mask don't like the eyes the
spider's okay I do think it's kind of
cool how on the arms he has the web
shooters right there that's nice I'm
going to go with another D tier here
although I will put that one at the top
of the D tiers up next we have
Spider-Man Noir complete with the frame
rate change people look at that
obviously a very cool character and I
really like this skin too I know we've
got kind of a theme so far loving all
the black and white skins but this one
really works if you imagine Spider-Man
is more of kind of a detective type
character similar to Batman instead of
the Spider-Man we know I think it's
great I'm going to go all the way up to
a tier for this one not quite s tier for
me but I think a pretty solid a tier the
IRA Knight suit here I'm assuming this
one is inspired by moonnight and it's
okay I mean The Capes look don't get me
wrong The Capes look cool hoods they
almost always look cool in video games
but something about the cape and the
hood on Spider-Man it just it doesn't
feel right to me yes it looks cool but
it it doesn't feel right I don't know I
can't explain it not really a fan of
these alternate Styles either so many of
these Styles here I feel like they give
you power ranger Vibes across a lot of
different suits which hey there's
nothing wrong with that I love me some
Power Rangers and the cape in the hood
actually in game I mean they do look
pretty good so if you enjoy capes and
hoods and you're okay with them being on
Spider-Man then I think this is
certainly a solid Choice all right but
now to the Sorting I'm going to put it
at the bottom of the B tiers top of the
S tiers I mean c te what the heck yeah I
think seat's here I think seat's here
maybe even below the iron spider one
here the anti o suit back here in
Spiderman 2 along with some new
variations I think the first one is the
best variation I loved it in the first
game and when you got it and the reasons
you got it and how you got it that was
all very cool and it even looks pretty
good here I just don't think it can rate
up next to some of the best suits in
this game some things I do like about it
the simplistic nature for one it's black
and gold again those two colors can work
really well together and they do they
work well together here the metallic
look I think it just works on this one
it makes sense for this suit given what
it is and I'm going to put it at the end
of the B tiers here I do think it's
better than the iron spider one up next
we have the superior suit and I'll just
tell you guys straight up one of my
favorite suits in the game we'll see
where I'm going to rank it here one of
my favorite suits though if you're going
to do red and black it needs to look
like this that red and black look so
stinking good together and even the
alternate Styles here I mean the blue
and black that actually looks really
good together definitely like the first
one best I do like the blue a lot more
than I expected I would this one's kind
of cool hold on though do you act wait
does it actually change the spider arms
to a neon green no way right dude it
does it does hold up we got to see what
that looks like in game let's take a
look at here nice okay that is pretty
cool now of course that also means that
this one here the one that we like the
most that should change them over to Red
let's just double check that yes you can
see right there all right then and here
it is actually in game and yeah you guys
I think that's an S tier suit man that
is an S tier suit s tier for our boy
superior Spider-Man gosh are we actually
going to try to rank between these maybe
later Scarlet Spider suit complete with
four different styles
um sorry not a fan of this suit guys not
a fan of this suit let's take a look in
game it looks a little bit better in
game than I thought it would but I don't
know just like how he has that top it
looks like he's wearing no pants or
something even though he very clearly
has pants on then the belt and the wrist
and the ankles no just not working for
me I would never wear this suit I'm not
going to put it in F tier I will put it
D tier and honestly I think it's
probably better than the homemade suit
just because it doesn't have the weird
sort of eyes that the homemade suit does
Spider-Man 2099 this is a freaking cool
suit it really is I I like all the
Styles actually if you want to go with
something crazy here and kind of have
this teal and purple you got the black
and white you got the black and red and
then you have what we saw in the movie
the Spider-Man 2099 suit here's how it
looks in game it's kind of like a cross
between Spider-Man and Batman you know
how he's got the little fins on the arm
there I guess that's what you call them
and then the texture on this one is so
good I mean you can tell that it's not
metallic yet it does sort of have this
really nice Sheen to it overall and the
spider in the front much more pronounced
tier oh it's not s tier for me but it is
solidly an a tier yeah for sure a tier
the amazing Tu suit we're getting closer
to that sort of classic Spider-Man look
that I love but again this this one is
just a little bit too dark it looks very
similar to let's see that webbed one
right there I do like it better than the
webbed one though oh man let's see a
tier or high B tier ooh I think I'm
going to go high B tier with that one up
next though we have the amazing suit and
something about this one you guys I
think it looks better in the game maybe
even than it did in the movie this one
has so many little details if you look
really closely you can even see the web
shooters just on the inside of his wrist
there I believe this style is from the
the Andrew Garfield Spider-Man movies
and I don't know there's something about
how they really nail the colors they get
the colors right and the texture that
they have here it works for me oh and
this one I'm torn I feel like it's going
to make a lot of people mad if I put
this one s tier I'm not sure what the
general Vibe sort of is on this one
again that's not what I should care
about that's not how I rank these anyway
but even me looking at it in comparison
to my other s tier so far I don't think
it's as good as those three I will put
it at the top of the a tiers though Tip
Top of the a tiers for sure the hybrid
suit meh just a just a general meh on
this one for me I'll put you in C tier
right away the Kumo suit man I I kind of
get what they were going for here but
guys it's it's an F tier for me I don't
get Spider-Man Vibes at all from this
suit I don't think I would ever wear
this one like at all next we have the
advanced suit which I believe this was
insomniacs from the first game I believe
they're the ones who designed this one
and honestly of these Styles man that
black and white I don't think I've even
seen that one yet that looks pretty fire
right there the standard one here though
hold on we shouldn't do this for every
suit but I feel like for this one it is
worth it to compare it to what they've
got now oh yeah the new one is so much
better yeah I okay I knew there was
something bother me about this one the
legs like see how the the red kind of
goes in and just stops sort of halfway
down the leg not really a fan of that
compare that to the black one though
where it's just kind of this dark gray
going down the side that actually looks
pretty slick okay yeah that suit is fire
right there how do we it though do we
consider all the Styles or just one
style cuz if it was just the black one I
think I would put it in the a tiers but
all of them and especially considering
that that one is the main one I'm going
to put it in B tier all right the
Scarlet 3 suit so again what we said
about the hoods it still stands here
although this one does not have a cape
so if you like The Capes then you
probably like this one a little bit less
if you're not a fan of The Capes then
you probably like this one a little bit
more of the different styles this black
and red is is kind of working for me I
don't know about this belt though it
looks like a Power Rangers Power Morpher
lots of Power Rangers references today
I'm think it's C tier on this one maybe
middle of the C tier o do I like it
better or worse than the moonight one I
think slightly slightly worse actually
all right people here it is the classic
suit and it is classic for a reason the
red and the blue they look so good
together and they really did a great job
on this version of the suit in the game
I think it looks really good here and
for me at least it is our first red and
blue s tier suit I got to put it in the
S tiers next we have the antivenom suit
and man of all the suits in the game
that I really want to like but just
don't this one is right there I I I want
to like the suit so much I do when you
get it in the game and that moment in
the game is obviously so epic it's such
an amazing moment but the suit I just
don't love it man the the white as the
dominant color just does not look good
on a Spider-Man suit at least in my
opinion the powers that you have with it
s tier that moment in the game s tier
but the suit itself gosh I don't think
it's quite c-tier I'm going to put it
here at the bottom of the B tiers though
all right so these next two I feel like
you almost have to rate these together
because of what they represent in the
game so you have the black suit this is
the one that you get first and you can
see it's much more alien than the
standard black suit that we've already
given an S tier and then the next one
here Insomniac is just calling the
symbiote suit and you can just see how
so much more the Symbio is taking over
all of the little tendrils there on top
it's very like muscular to me compared
to the other one and to be honest with
you guys I really like both of these
suits I think they also both look really
good in the game I think how they did it
and how they showed it progressing
throughout the game I think that was all
great I mean just look at this suit here
look at this suit and then just for
comparison here it is with the symbiote
suit so when you're playing in game I
mean you can tell a little bit of a
difference especially with the head and
the arms right there when you're web
swinging not quite as much see I don't
want to let how good this suit is affect
how i rate these because let's imagine
that we didn't have this one for a
second would we rate these in s tier I
think I personally would actually I'm
putting both of those symbiote suits up
there in s tier with the others and then
we have the advanced suit 2.0 complete
with four different styles the first one
by far my favorite second one is okay
third and fourth though just not a fan
at all those and I think this one is
definitely better than the first version
of the Insomniac Spider-Man suit it's
still a little too busy for me but I
really genuinely love this suit guys I'm
right now I'm torn between s tier and a
tier I think it's that good I don't know
man maybe it's the marketing working on
me where I've seen this in all the
advertisements all the box art and
everything I really like this suit
though but where do we go guys does it
rise all the way up to S tier I'll tell
you one thing right now just from
looking at this I don't like the fact
that I only have one red and blue suit
in the S tier category it is too iconic
of a look for me not to have more up
there so we're going to do it man we're
going to put the Insomniac I think
that's 2.0 Spider-Man suit in the S tier
category if you guys enjoyed this video
I just finished up my platinum trophy
run of Marvel Spider-Man 2 absolutely
phenomenal game had a blast with it and
I posted my full trophy hunt over on my
brand new trophy hunting channel we've
got several videos over there already
including Spider-Man Miles Morales and
Spider-Man 2 check it out over there on
the left side of your screen now as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon